welcome to another edition of Armageddon
the best thing the Chess Club ever does
okay so we have two players tied in the
millionaire chest satellite aspirin
German an international master
priyadarshan canopen they both finished
the event four and a half out of five as
you might recall from last year Ashwin
is returning through another of a good
match last time he had a match against
Jake layman and let's just say he got
the trip to Vegas okay listen up all
right ashman he won the event on
tiebreaks so he gets his choice he can
either take white and six minutes and
must win the match to go to Vegas or
take the black pieces and have a four
minutes and draw it meaning he could win
the match or just take a draw just so
there's no confusion if I see a
three-fold repetition or the same
position three times are I got 250 I
will declare the game a draw ok so right
yes still illegal moves to lose and that
includes putting a pawn on the back row
and hitting the clock all right so
without further ado Ashwin what is your
choice black pieces a second the black
pieces all right that's more right it is
touch boom obviously you have no legal
move with a piece of touch you are not
required to move all right gentlemen go
ahead and start the clock aastra
I
congratulations master plan now the big
question is do you really want to accept
the perfect is all right it's going a
bit yes all right well it feels great
because last year I came like super
close and I played with the same opened
Ashwin and the final ground I had to win
to qualify but I lost so he got a chance
to play the Armageddon qualified so it
was like a disappointment last year this
kind I thought you know it makes her
that no I bit him and Armageddon and
made qualified this vicar I haven't
played one in official capacity or an
unofficial capacity so this was my first
arm again ever and this was also a
pretty interesting arm again I was
hoping today morning when I woke up I
was thinking this is most probably going
to be there is an Armageddon generally
they do by like you know you write down
the time between both the players and
which are the lowest i even had a
specific time in my mind which i should
be writing it because in the morning was
pretty sure i'll be there will be an
Armageddon and i will be there i was
pretty sure about that and I was close
to be bidding around four minutes and
two seconds if there was such an option
so I was slightly mentally prepared for
Armageddon I think that helped me a bit
but obviously shouldn't more experienced
than me to be played last year's
Armageddon so I was pretty nervous I was
like really motivated to win this and
and especially as I am now looking to
improve my speed rating as I'm going for
my GM title milliner open is a federated
event and I can play all these super
GM's everyone who's playing there so
it'll be a great opportunity for me that
was like the main motivator for me swear
I can play all these GM sentra
score well and this year when I saw the
pre-registration list is already not
caruana name and Lake Nakamura so it's
like this this even this much bigger
than the previous year so this is
getting much better if every year I
think it gives chance for technically
non-professional place I i would say
people you know who are less than 2,600
reading it gives them a chance to win
huge price money which is just a big
thing because chess has always been a
sport where extremely high rated players
when a lot of money and then people
lesser than that maybe get max that one
thousand dollars if they've been a
tournament but this tournament gives
them chance to win like forty thousand
dollars twenty thousand dollars so it's
a really cool thing that just players
can also if they hit the jackpot I mean
it motivates them to work even harder
during the last year interview I told
that it would be great if they had more
satellite tournaments and I know that
this year they had tournaments in Africa
and so it's getting much better I was
like really happy because last year the
only satellite was st. Louis and there
was no other satellite ornaments from an
open this year I saw the 34 in Africa
being conducted by cash purchase
foundation yeah so I hope that's like
more and more satellites and coming
years and more and more participation in
moline are open special thanks to a
great master Boris Ashley for helping us
put on such a great event and hopefully
priyadarshan will do wonders in Vegas
all right
you